the Constitution that says does not live
in the mind of anybody who they all had
different ideas right some of them
different some of the same and they
fought like cats and dogs and the best
of them and most of them after it was
written slaughtered something more
beautiful and better than any of them
could have conceived Catholic and also
key doesn't work so it's no use writing
the hand to this riot of madison lee
long they agreed finally and we got the
greatest instrument of government ever
written by a long marching and if you
can't see that you can't see anything
the point I want to make is single we're
at a stage now for the loss of our
Liberty is a prospect interview that
could happen people know we should act
like this it is not given to us to
guarantee that we will fix these
problems or we can stand up by the men
and women of strength and we study and
we can make sure that whatever happens
to the last one we and representative
the wisest and the best of course
whatever the tax it's the time for that
and that is a liberating thing and the
examples how to do it our written